Clones, crocodiles,
conspiracies:
Resident Evil has them all.
And unpicking
all those mysteries
may require some help.
We're here
to fill in the gaps
and explain the implications
of hidden details,
as we answer
the biggest questions
raised by the show's ending.
We're about to inject
a whole dose of spoilers
straight into your veins,
so make sure you've
watched Resident Evil first.
At the end of the series,
we see Jade and Billie
fleeing New Raccoon City
in 2022,
and an older Billie
kidnapping Jade's daughter
in 2036.
The trickiest part
of Resident Evil
is juggling
those two timelines,
with Jade and Billie
pre-apocalypse adventures
in 2022,
and Jade fighting
for her life,
14 years later.
What we don't see
in the 2022 flashbacks
is how 2036
went to the dogs,
zombified or otherwise,
and why Billie
turned on Jade.
But throughout the show,
we're given hints
to fill in some gaps.
When 2036 Jade
is caught in episode one,
the bounty hunters spot
her identity number
from New Raccoon City…
She's a survivor.
…and confirm this is where
the zombie outbreak began.
Your ink.
You were in the New Raccoon
when the outbreak started.
As to why Billie
shoots Jade in 2036,
we do see some conflict
between the sisters in 2022,
but the real indicator
hides in Billie's speech.
She mentions events
that have yet
to happen in the show.
You ever notice how everyone
around you somehow…
dies?
Simon.
Bert.
Kim, Hiroki… Dad.
Their dad blew up
destroying Umbrella's lab,
and Simon is killed
by his mum
after being bitten
by Billie.
#World'sWorstMother.
But in the 2022 timeline,
Bert is still alive
and drives off
with the girls.
And we've yet
to meet characters
called Kim and Hiroki -
a clear sign
that the sisters' journey
from strained siblings
to sworn enemies
has plenty of secrets
yet to be revealed.
Stay the fuck away from her.
At the end of the season,
we see something gnarly
doing his best
Carrie impersonation.
The claw belongs
to this nasty-looking chap,
previously contained
in Umbrella's laboratory,
until Albert blows it up.
And while we don't see
what triggers
the zombie outbreak in 2022,
we'd bet a yearly supply
of Joy pills
on it having something to do
with this guy.
To understand why,
we need to quickly talk
about the T-Virus.
It's mentioned at several
points in the show,
and has a long history
in the wider
Resident Evil universe.
But the drug contains
a derivative of the T-Virus,
a pathogen
we originally developed
for the American military.
That project was… ill-fated.
The T-Virus
was a mutagenic plague
engineered by the Umbrella
Corporation in the 1970s.
This isn't a pharmaceutical
company we see in the show,
but a gang of mad scientists
mutating people
into monsters
for military purposes.
They create the T-Virus,
and the Resident Evil games,
all set before the show,
are about heroes
fighting the creatures
that escape as a result.
Evelyn Marcus does
hint at this dark past.
The old Umbrella, my father
made his share of mistakes,
but this is not
that company.
And she would know.
In the games,
there is a character called
James Marcus, her dad.
In the 2022 timeline,
the T-Virus still exists,
albeit as a strain
in Umbrella's Joy pills.
And this explains the weird
and wonderful creatures
seen throughout the show.
T-Virus does
different things
to different subjects.
People mostly
become zombies,
but it can also mutate them
into Lickers,
the guys
with the horrible tongues
living in
the Channel Tunnel.
Wouldn't happen
on the Eurostar.
If the virus gets
into animals,
it increases their size,
explaining
the giant spiders,
Jade's caterpillar friend,
and the scariest crocodile
this side of Peter Pan.
As for our friend
in the rubble,
he resembles
the ultimate form
the virus takes
in the games:
the tyrant,
an unstoppable killing
machine with massive claws.
Which is why releasing him
from his tank
is likely to be
very bad news
for the people in 2022.
We learn in the series
that Jade and Billie's dad,
Albert Wesker, is not
Father of the Year material.
He is, in fact, a clone
of another Albert Wesker.
Let's call him "OG" Wesker,
a former Umbrella scientist
who made copies of himself
to work on secret
science projects.
We meet three clones
in the show:
Albert, Bert and Alby.
Alby dies
when Umbrella soldiers
storm OG Wesker's lab…
…leaving Bert,
who was the unhinged
breadstick-loving clone…
More breadsticks.
…and Albert,
father to Jade and Billie.
We learn that this Albert
genetically modified
his daughters
so that their blood
could keep him alive.
As a clone, his body
wasn't built to endure.
At the end of the season,
Albert sacrifices himself
and leaves the teens
to escape with Bert.
The use of clones
also explains
how Albert Wesker,
or a version of him,
is alive in 2022.
In the Resident Evil
universe, OG Wesker,
the mastermind with the cool
glasses and leather coat,
fell into some lava
in 2009 -
a fact the show
does reference.
He was killed by
the original Albert Wesker,
our creator.
Creator?
We were part of a research
and development team
he put together to help him.
He died in a volcano.
It's okay though.
He wasn't very nice.
Yeah, it was a whole thing.
If you're familiar
with the wider
Resident Evil universe,
it does explain a few
moments in the season.
We see OG Wesker
in a flashback to 2005,
set in a place called
the Arklay Mountains.
This is the location
of the very first
Resident Evil game,
where Umbrella
made the T-Virus.
It's also OG Wesker
we see and hear
in a tape the sisters find
in their dad's hidden room.
The video shows Wesker
injecting a mutated woman
named Lisa.
Again, she's a character
from the first game,
Lisa Trevor,
who appears in this
horrific, monstrous form.
Oh, and if you're wondering
where dad Albert
gets his weird approach
to home security,
the tune the girls play on
the piano to unlock his room
is Beethoven's
"Moonlight Sonata",
which you played on a piano
in the original
Resident Evil game
to unlock
a different secret room.
In fact,
the whole fifth episode,
"Family Movies",
feels like a love letter
to Resident Evil puzzles.
Blowing a dog whistle
to grab a key
from a dog's collar
is another conundrum
from the game.
You chipped fuzzy baby.
One final mystery
from the ending:
before his explosive
resignation,
Albert writes the name of
a helpful contact on a note.
In the final shots
of the show,
this is revealed
to read "Ada Wong".
Like OG Wesker,
she's another key character
in the Resident Evil
universe,
a spy whose
shifting alliances
could never be pinned down.
That she works
outside of Umbrella,
or at least did
in her video-game past,
would suggest she's a wise
person to turn to,
given
their current situation.
In the wider universe,
Ada first appeared in 1998
during a zombie outbreak
in the original
Raccoon City.
This is the event referenced
throughout the show.
The girls find
reference to it
in their dad's 1998 files,
and they learn that things
didn't end well there.
Do you know what happened
to the first Racoon City?
Some kind of gas leak,
a big fire or something.
No, no, no, it was destroyed
by a nuclear blast.
But hey, if Ada survived
one zombie apocalypse,
maybe she can
survive another.
Intriguingly, her address
is listed as Tokyo.
Does this hint at more
globetrotting to come?
A trip to Japan
would explain
how Jade and Billie
could meet a Hiroko,
one of the mystery
characters Billie says
Jade has killed
between 2022 and 2036.
Only time will tell.
And so we've reached
the end of Resident Evil,
a world with
as many brainteasers
as it has brain-munchers.
Why not share your own
theories in the comments?
And if you enjoyed
this breakdown,
subscribe to
Still Watching Netflix
for more videos like it.